tell me about your plans for year 35
plans to stay healthy
happy Dr vaish Kumar was bright happy
and looking forward to the future
but when she began working here at the
Queen Elizabeth Hospital in Birmingham
things changed at a trust now exposed
for a toxic culture of bullying Dr Kumar
was belittled and laughed at and would
often go home in tears she took her own
life last summer and left a note for her
parents blaming the hospital
each day is a struggle it's
it makes me angry
and at the same time
worried about the other Junior doctors
who are going to follow her
the report found Dr Kumar was not the
first doctor at this trust to take her
own life it highlighted a long-standing
bullying and toxic environment where
staff fear retribution if concerns were
raised and warns any continuance of a
culture that is corrosively affecting
morale and in particular threatens
long-term staff Recruitment and
Retention will put at risk the care of
patients this trust has a patient death
rate that's 10 percent higher than would
be expected the report found that if the
culture here isn't already affecting
mortality rates it's likely it is
affecting the treatment that patients
receive
consultant eye surgeon Tristan rooser
won a case of unfair dismissal against
the trust
a former Chief Executive had referred
him to the General Medical Council
without mentioning he was a
whistleblower who'd raised concerns
about unsafe Staffing levels the current
permit members of the board have been
part of the culture of fear and the
mafia-like culture unless they go
nothing will change they're all part of
the same culture they have to go
the new chief executive insists concerns
are being addressed
we are listening I am listening I have
done so much listening so much
engagement about all of the things that
people are unhappy about in this
organization I am committed to making
sure that we change
but this report paints a damning picture
of one of England's largest NHS trusts
Becky Johnson Sky News Birmingham